hi everyone my name is Shane Augustine
I'm a post doctoral fellow at ni Triple
A in the laboratory for integrative
neuroscience under the supervision of
dr. David Levenger today I'm going to
share some still-developing work with
everyone and it's unpublish we're
actively and vigorously working on this
line of research it's part of my k99
grant that I was recently awarded and I
will tell you about some new cyclic MP
sensors that were testing and optimizing
for in vivo application as well as some
work that we've started with the PJ
sensor and of course I would like to
thank the organizers for from lab roots
neuroscience 2020 for inviting me to
share my research when if we're
interested in the brain depicted here on
the right is a basal ganglia circuit
diagram a simplified version of it the
basal ganglia are a group of subcortical
nuclei that's involved in purposeful
actions and are oftentimes affected in
many neurological disorders the stratum
sits at the center of the basal ganglia
it receives inputs from various parts of
cortex including limbic and thalamic
cortical motor systems it also receives
inputs from dopaminergic areas such as a
suspension [ __ ] we're interested in a
neural basis of decision making we're
particularly interested in how
information flows through these circuits
to affect behavior various behaviors
such as action initiation action control
and action learning but we're not only
interested in what happens on a circuit
level we're interested in what happens
on a synaptic level we know that
cellular changes can lead to changes and
excitability as well as short-term or
long-term transmission which can
ultimately affect circuit
thereby affecting behavior we know that
there's two types of neuronal
communication both are activated by like
and finding iron atrophic receptors or
fast actin in which the ligand binds
thereby causing activation opening a
closing of a channel or metabotropic
receptors are slower actin because these
receptors signal through second
messengers metabotropic receptors have
been implicated in fear in virtually all
function cellular functions and are
often the target of many neurological
diseases and are often affected as well
what we're interested in is how is it
that
gpcrs signal through limited downstream
signaling pathways how is inflammation
maintained and encoded so that the cells
are guided to its appropriate response
despite having a limited number of
g-protein as well as downstream
signaling pathways we're interested in
how these second messengers change in a
temporal resolution as well as the
spatial resolution and how this differ
join different parts of behavior during
the acquisition phase versus to learn
and phase well I was also interested in
how these sub cellular molecules
interact with each other
for example new modulators such as
dopamine and calcium as well as other
sensors such as like a KP and dopamine
and calcium so we're really interested
in looking at these sub cellular changes
in vivo while the animals are actively
learning a task
we're currently testing two cyclic and P
sensors and we're optimizing them for in
vivo application
once one sensor depicted on the left is
a single wavelength lesson sensor and on
the right is a fret based sensor they
both share very similar domain structure
with the intensive intensity based
sensor catus one cyclicamp it binds to
the regulatory domain we have a
conformational change in which the
catalytic and the regulatory region
comes closer together causing the GFP
protein to fluoresce the fret based
sensor which is they're both derived
from a pack to the EPAct sensor the fret
based sensor has the similar design
however we're using for us at lifetime
to quantify that activity fret is a
phenomenon in which you have a transfer
of energy from donor to acceptor in this
case in the absence of cyclicamp ii the
donor fluorophore is actually very close
to the acceptor for core so you have
instances of fret this results in a
shorter lifetime the donor in our sensor
is M tall boys in the presence of
cyclicamp P on cyclic AMP it binds to
the regulatory region the donor floral
which is an turquoise moves further away
from our venous flow force and this
results in a longer donor lifetime first
we'll talk about some experiments that I
have started using the intensity base
sensor we're interested in looking at
changes in live brain slice as well as
in vivo and in order to look at changes
in live brain slice with our intensity
based sensor we're using brain slice
photometry this uses a photomultiplier
base photometry system depicted on the
right the lower right of my schematic is
a coronal Strato section we can take or
we can zoom in to a small region of inch
and in many cases it's 180 by 180
microns we then shine blue light onto
the surface of our slice to activate GFP
light is emitted from our sample it's
filtered through appropriate filters and
the voltage output from our PMT is then
fed into our computer seen on the left
is actually our experimental output this
shutter opens on the bottom the shutter
opens we have blue light the F value is
actually our baseline value or a
background fluorescence we can
electrically stimulate a response as
seen here in this case it's actually
cyclic AMP II and we can have a you for
fluorescence increase which is our Delta
F we can compare things such as our
Delta F over F so peak changes versus
over our baseline and we can also look
at changes in our background
fluorescence the shutter stays open for
some time and then it closes again
depicted here on the left is a schematic
in which we've actually expressed our
caddis which is our cyclic AMP intensity
based sensor into a particular subset of
neurons in this case it's a d1 creep
that were using to express our caddis
sensor in d1 medium spiny neurons in the
striatum we know that these medium spiny
neurons contain dopamine d1 receptors
and these receptors upon activation are
positively coupled to cyclic amp team at
the top the first response we see is we
can electrically stimulate and we can
evoke an increase in cyclic AMP E as
depicted here by an increase in
fluorescence intensity
and if we dare by and this is what 200
micro second duration stimulation if we
then increase our stimulation duration
to one millisecond we can thereby
further increase our cyclic AMP II
response as depicted here in red as an
increase or an increase in fluorescence
intensity the next question that we were
interested in accident is whether or not
this response is actually synaptic or
some technical error of our system or
set up we actually washed on TTX at one
micromolar and depicted here on the
bottom there's a representative we can
evoke a nice response which is our black
and baseline and in the presence of TTF
this response goes away so it's
dimension to diminish this is indicating
that our response is indeed synaptic if
we washed on on to our slice 10
micromolar Foss color what we see is an
increase in background persons so far
scaling is an activator of cyclic AMP II
and thereby this increases our
background first and so it increases
like gimpy
next we were wondering where is cat X
being expressed in this population of
neuron seen here is a two-photon image
of our brain slice and baseline
measurement we can see very dimly what
could be dendrite after washing on
postulant
and IBM X so far scaling as an activator
Italian cyclist and IBM X is a
phosphodiesterase inhibitor this is done
to increase cyclic AMP II what we see is
a change in for us as depicted here and
what we can see now seeing nicely the
dendrites of the cell and as well as the
cell body or in the process of actually
one of
the rest of our data but this is good
indication because what is not seen and
what our slice photometry method is
actually where these thing where our
sensor is expressed and this is good a
good test to us that is actually
expressed in the dendrites as well as
the cell body within our sub slice
preparation next we wanted to express
the caddis sensor and the dorsal eros
try them however at this time in d2
MSN's
we did that by using an HOA cree we know
that the two is up D to Amazon's contain
d2 receptors these receptors are
negatively coupled to cyber can't peek
so activation of those receptors would
decrease cyclic AMP
what we see once we stimulate we see a
downward deflection even though it's
very small we're still able to resolve
these changes this speaks to the power
of using our technique which is the
slice photometry technique using PMT's
if we did the same thing using R as we
did with the d1 MSM if we increase the
duration width of our stimulation we can
modulate that effect so we can further
decrease or see a further decrease in
cyclic AMP e again acts in the same
question whether or not this response is
indeed real is a synaptic or something
else we washed on one micromolar of t TX
as depicted on the bottom and what you
see is that the response goes away when
the process of looking at how this
signal is affected by postulant as well
as IBM X so this fits with what we know
in the literature about the 1ms
incentive to limit zones and that
activation of these receptors through
dopamine my result in d1 and lessons
leading to increases in cyclicamp
evening that they positively couple
indeed to a my son's leave in 2d pieces
in psychic NP because they're negative
next we wanted to look at dopamine
release wild measuring on cyclic AP in
our slices and in order to do this we
synchronize our brain size photometry
system with fast and cyclic voltammetry
to the same stimulation so in order to
measure dopamine in this case we're
using a carbon fiber that has been
inserted into a glass electrode and what
we're doing we're grabbed in we're
raising and lowering the voltage very
rapidly in the sraight 'm at our region
of interest and this causes the
oxidation and reduction of dopamine this
causes a small electrical current that
were able to measure and were able to
measure mono amines such as dopamine
because each our monoamine has a unique
current voltage on relationship so this
is really really good we really wanted
to do this for a long time are we able
to do it so we're simultaneously
recording changes inside the campi and
opening to the same stimulation and this
is what we see so depicted on the top we
can just look at the representative
traces at first at the top we're looking
at dopamine and at the bottom we're
looking at d1 MSN psychic MP so we're
expressing cyclic AMP E or the caddis
we're expressing catice in d1 MSS and
what we see with dopamine with a single
pulse we see a nice in black we see a
nice dopamine response we also see at
the bottom in black and I said that can
be a response
I have to say that we did with and
without dage beta e th beta e is a
nicotinic with nicotinic or as nicotine
sorry nicotinic acetylcholine receptor
antagonist and what we see once we wash
on the H beta II where dopamine we see a
reduction in dopamine and we also see a
reduction in cyclic AMP II this seems to
be a one-to-one relationship being that
if there's less dopamine around this
less dopamine to activate our T 1
receptor resulting in the cyclic AMP II
if we then apply six pulses of 50 Hertz
this work has been shown by Stephanie
Craig in 2004 what you see is actually
an enhancement or believe or relief from
the DHB te suppression with one pole so
you actually get a bigger dopamine
response in the presence of th beta e
with more on physics simulation however
would cyclic AMP II what we see in the
presence of the H beta II is actually
less of an inhibition so they seem to be
that one-to-one relationship has now
been interrupted and now we're
stimulating their 50 Hertz there's other
things being released other
neuromodulators being released in
striatum and that might contribute to
why we see less of an inhibition
depicted on the far right on top is just
a bar graph with the percentage change
and dopamine in which we see with one p
or one paul stimulation we actually see
maybe a seventy percent decrease whereas
with the frequency stimulation at 50
Hertz we see a 20 percent increase who
cyclicamp ed1 psychic MP towards the
bottom please forgive me the axis is
wrong it's not % baseline dopamine is
actually a percent baseline cyclic and P
and what
see is a 90% reduction with one pause
and less of an inhibition or less of a
reduction with the HP the import again
the axes the y axis is actually percent
baseline of cyclicamp e it's not
dopamine next we're interested in
looking at a pack which is a fat based
sensor the fat based sensor offers many
advantages or unlike intensity based
sensor these sensors are less sensitive
to photo bleaching also on sensor
concentration light scattering deep down
in deep brain structures therefore we
can use lifetime measurement to quantify
productivity and that have to deal with
any of the troubleshoot or any of the
problems that might create more
intensity based sensor we've tested our
epoch sensor in X Y States as seen in
the middle as you increase the
concentration of cyclic amp P you get
longer lifetimes which seems to fit also
in heck cells if we wash on Faustian and
a bunch of micro molar we see a shift in
the lifetime measurement so again longer
lifetime which indicates more cyclic AMP
II but like I started off this morning
or had to be not this morning but at the
beginning of my talk I said we wanted to
use this for in vivo applications so in
order to use a pack a pack is a very
large protein our epoch protein is
approximately 800 amino acid not
including the floor force the film fours
are approximately 230 amino acid each
and we have an turquoise and toothiness
molecules and in order to actually
package the epod structure into a navy
phone we had the help of a staff
scientist and
commenters lab which is dr. Steve Lobel
but dr. Henry Ford actually engineered
this virus in which he used an NT in
structure that brings both halves of the
structures together all part of the
virus the C Thomason internals together
by this
Anton region that spices up and it's a
protein intron almost and what we can do
is that only when the two halves of the
e pack structure comes together do we
actually see fluorescence we have
expressed this two-part virus in the
dorsal lateral striatum as seen here we
can get nice fluorescence as seen in the
middle and if we actually take straddle
tissue from bring we can actually pull
out the protein as indicated in the
western blot and is of the same size as
the intact and terminus and C terminus
so we do believe that our virus our epic
virus and brain this is actually coming
together correctly and is of the right
size however was there in the process of
testing this in vivo in a way behaving
animals but what we have been able to
test so far is T ta car alpha it's a PT
a sensor that's developed by tianni
Mouse dr. T Ani Mouse poop from Oregon
and in order to do this we're using
time-correlated single photon counting
fiber photometry in vivo this allows us
to use a multimode fiber for excitation
as well as photon emission and this
allows us to do more chronic long-term
experiments using this system we can get
both changes in intensity soap it
changes into intensity as well as
lifetime measurement so using this one
system we can look at arm sensors such
as caddis which is more intensity
but we can also look at EPA and this
newly optimized sensor which is lifetime
base fried based on source and we've
been able to do that again the sensor
was published in the newly optimized
sensor was published in 2018
it measures PKA phosphorylation and join
PKA phosphorylation you have instances
of high fret that leads to shorter
lifetime shorter gfp lifetime we're able
to express this sensor in the stratum
one of the questions we were interested
in accident is whether or not their
tonic levels of PKA signal in stride all
the moments in freely moving animals so
we anesthetized and I'm several animals
with one point five percent I so Florian
and what we saw in the Delta lifetime of
the lifetime we saw an increase and
Delta lifetime over life time
measurement this represents a decrease
in PKA phosphorylation so this data set
seems to suggest that indeed there are
tonic levels of PKA signaling and
creaming with animals in striatal
neurons next we wanted to look at a
behavioral relevant task so we know that
in on Rhoda rod there are experience
dependent changes that occur on day one
of rotor our training and we know that
this is dependent on region dorsal
lateral dorsal medial search region
selective and is also dependent on input
input specificity and we know that
different inputs are engaged based on
previous work from our laboratory so we
set up our photometry system and the
rotor our system in which the photometry
door dart system triggers the start of
the photometry system and what we see on
day one the animals can learn so this is
just our thr alpha which are peak
a sensor expressed in straddle nerves
and the dorsal stratum of c57 male
animals it's not create a pendant it's
an all neurons early on there is some
improvement so if you look on the far
left and latency to fall on day one the
animals were subjected to 10 trials and
there is some learning that occurred the
first 3 trials if you time lock the
lifetime measurement there is a small
increase in lifetime measurements which
represents a decrease of PKA
phosphorylation if you then look later
on in training on day one which is we're
calling it early this decrease in PKA
phosphorylation seems to go away if we
then look at the 5 so we train the
animals on for five consecutive days and
from day 2 to day 5 they received 5
trials per day and if we look later on
in training they seems to be no change
in PKA phosphorylation later on in
training this is really encouraging
because this tells us that there are
some PK dynamics that occur during
different time points of learning in
this task and that's something where
we're actively looking at and we're
exploring and we'll continue just to
conclude what I'll tell told you so far
is that we now have a second MP single
wavelength sensor so intensity based
sensors was a Phet based sensor that can
be used in brain slices and possibly in
vivo we know that our TCS PCR
time-correlated single photon counting
fiber photometry system developed by our
lab in 2014 can be used to measure a
lifetime measurement and phurba sensors
we know that there are tonic levels of
PK activity in Charlotte neurons
and we also know that they seem to be a
dynamic interplay with peaky
not interplay by the dynamic PG dynamics
that occur during the learning of a
skills such as world a lot I would like
to thank my mentors my primary mentor
dr. David love the joy as well as my
cool mentor dr. stephen volcko my
colleagues of my laboratory such as
Yolanda Jang and amando as well as my
students Alexa mashido and everyone else
they have contributed to this line of
research thank you for listening to me
and if you have any questions please
send me an e-mail I'll be more than
happy to ensure that thank you